[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt bzw ist es sogar schon mittags
sehe ich gerade ich habe die letzte
folge minecraft mit luca ja hier oben
beendet wo wir mein wohnzimmer
beziehungsweise es wird tatsächlich das
schlafzimmer sein hab ich noch mal
nachgeguckt wo wir das hier ein bisschen
fertig gebaut haben beziehungsweise
überhaupt erst mal angefangen haben mit
dem flachbildschirm schöne anderen
sideboard aus an die sid mit einer
pflanze hier mit dem kleinen
kleiderschrank ich habe nur gerade
gedacht dass es vielleicht von da unten
bisschen schöner ist das ganze zu
starten wenn man auch das ist
schon alles schön wie wir das gemacht
haben die sache ist allerdings mit neben
freude dass wir heute wirklich und da
könnt ihr mich beim wort nehmen die
strandvilla endlich mal fertig bauen
werden wir
werden das wirklich machen hier vorne
kommt das bettchen hin hier vorne kommt
noch ein kleines nachtisch ihn hier
vorne müssen wir dann auch noch mal in
den raum rein da kommt nämlich das
badezimmer rein dafür benötigen wir
allerdings eine menge sachen erstmal
noch ich hoffe dass ich genügend kraft
habe um das ganze heute fertig fertig
feldes fertig ich hoffe dass ich
genügend quarz habe um das ganze heute
perfekt fertigzustellen die sache ist
allerdings dass wir uns nicht nur
quatsch holen müssen sondern auch einige
andere dinge und für eine sache fahre
ich auch schon mal direkt rüber auf
unsere trauer in seiner freunde denn wir
benötigen einen bienenstock
ich war als frage ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich mensch luca warum
brauchst nur in der modernen strandhaus
will audi ist wirklich sehr sehr modern
so dass die zecke heil aus welcher gar
nicht gesehen mit dem glas hier vorne
auch mit dieser kleinen dings was ja
unser tunnels sagt dahinden ihr fragt
euch allerdings wahrscheinlich menschen
luca waren brauchst nun bienenstock gute
frage ich weiß ich finde das sieht
ehrlich gesagt als teil aufwendig
viel habe ich schon mal gemacht wo ist
es wo ich hab sie damit genau den fehler
habe schon mal nicht die oma idiot ich
habe genau den gleichen fehler schon mal
gemacht und jetzt ist auch noch weg oder
was
[Musik]
das mit herbert abschließend
abgestimmt jetzt nicht
ja
das habe ich auch gesehen ich weiß nicht
ob wir fordern auch einen anderen
bienenstock haben ich hoffe einfach mal
weil ich glaube wirklich dass wir
irgendwie eine menge am start hat nach
8,4 ist auch noch einer also mit
behutsamkeit sollte es jetzt glaube ich
klappte perfekt da haben wir nämlich
jetzt hier das bienen ist
muss ich so machen
[Musik]
wie ist gerade mal aufgefallen dass wir
dieses bienen es gar nicht benötigen wir
benötigen wirklich nur die honigwaben
und die habe ich ja gerade dadurch
bekommen dass ich mit der schere
rechtsklick darauf gemacht habe wir
benötigen sogar wirklich nur diese
das sehe ich wir müssen jetzt auf jeden
fall unsere drei honigwaben nehmen und
die um branden oben und unten mit
eichenholz blätter beziehen wir ganz
normalen holzbrettern von daher mache
ich das jetzt mal und ich werde auch
ich dich detail apps machen wie ich mir
nämlich alle sachen hole die ich für die
strandhaus werder benötige
[Musik]
so meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich habe gerade tatsächlich mehr als 20
minuten lang diese ganzen sachen hier
zusammengekaufte da sind unter anderem
glos dauern dabei da sind rahmen dabei
haken banner aber auch unter anderem
wieder ein blumentopf wir haben diesmal
auch ein gemälde wieder mit am start
also einige dinge haben wir dort auf
jeden fall zusammen uns gesucht zuvor
hin das hat ein bisschen gedauert denn
es war wirklich eine menge weil ich mir
auch gedacht habe mensch wenn ich das
ding jetzt endlich fertig bauen will
dann will ich das jetzt auch in einer
folge machen und jetzt nicht bereit mich
an
warum die geistes tag
und möchte mich nicht mit seinen links
hier mitnehme
[Musik]
weiß dass
das hier vielleicht auch noch andere
monster sein könnten wenn hier schon
einiges bond ist
[Musik]
ich habe mir noch ein bisschen angst vor
kratzern meine damen und herrn wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt sicher auftrieb
sondern endlich mal auf diese bude hier
denn hier vorne kommt unser bettchen hin
und zwar nehmen wir dafür hier zwei
blöcke abstand zu unserem kleiderschrank
sodass wir sind eigentlich gerade
ist aber auch egal wen ich hier auf
jeden fall zwei blöcke abstand
12345 setzen hier fünf blöcke hin und
jetzt hier oben drauf noch einmal drei
glatte quartz stufen das jetzt so ein
bisschen so die rückenlehne und wenn man
sich so leicht anlehnen kann könnte aber
auch eine ablage sein jetzt nehmen
allerdings unsere glatten quatsch wovon
gehen hier 12 34 und hier auch ein zwei
drei vier
in die länge hier liegen wir nämlich
dann und das hier wird das endstück des
betts als kopfkissen habe ich mir schnee
blöcke überlegt die kommt man nicht so
anordnung dann hier drunter neuen graue
wolle die so ein bisschen die decke
darstellen und dann ist das hier unser
bettchen und nun nehmen wir unseren
schnee und setzen hier einen drauf hier
und hier zwei das sollen sie ein
bisschen die kissen darstellen dass hier
bauen wir jetzt mal raus und setzen nun
hier vorne links unseren blumentopf rein
da habe ich meinen pflichten setzen
mitgenommen haben hier so eine kleine
ein bisschen natur haben wir dann hier
und auf dieser seite hier er hat er im
video links genommen so schildkröt naja
die konnte ich allerdings sich abbauen
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich stell
dir einfach so ein paar kerzen hin wenn
sie das ganze so aus ich weiß nicht ob
ich das so lasse oder ob ich das ganze
vielleicht irgendwie so mache einfach
nur ich glaube ich dass es so erst mal
stehen oder hier vielleicht auch eine
hin können wir mal gucken könnte mir
auch gerne in die kommentare schreiben
wie ihr das hier machen würde den in der
mitte würde ich aber vielleicht sogar
wegnehmen dann vielleicht auch erst mal
hier zu setzen aber so sieht irgendwie
blöd aus weil er dann so 2 direkt
nebenan da sind es könnten aber auch
zwei klebten sagte wir machen das jetzt
einfach erst mal so und die setzt sich
erstmal provisions mäßig in die mitte
oder nämlich doch weg ich glaube ich
dass sie erst mal freilich dass das erst
mal ich hätte sie doch in die mitte
sorgt bitte lange rede kurzer sinn wir
lassen das jetzt einfach mal so und nun
nehmen wir hier für die rechte seite
unseren dienen stock und setzen darauf
einfach eine laterne dann haben wir ein
bisschen so ein kleines nachttisch gerät
hier vorne rum
die sache ist jetzt dass wir hierfür
tote korallen benötigen die sehen nicht
so aus wie teppiche und da brauche ich
die gelben korallen das sind nämlich so
gelbe korallen
fachverkäufer ich weiß nicht genau wie
teilweisen ich weiß auch nicht so
richtig wie ich die teile aber wenn ich
da einmal gegen schlage dann gehen sie
kaputt wenn ich allerdings eine
betriebsamkeit spitzhacke nehme dann
klappt das ganze perfekt durch diese
gelben hier sind auf jeden fall ich
schon immer ganz gut so die heizen
gewalt korallen fächer so dass sie nicht
nicht bewerbe fachverkäufer was hab ich
gerade gesagt
nun endlich luft anhalten ist noch nicht
so drin ich habe jetzt hier unten die 20
grad
was wollen die denn immer
und wo kommen die her
schwimmen wollte ich jetzt eigentlich
normalen die ist doch alles
ausgeleuchtet bei mir ich hab keine
ahnung wo diese spinnen die ganze zeit
spawnen allerdings muss ich jetzt mal
oft dieses bettchen hier oder eins von
diesen bettchen hier zurückgreifen kann
ich dir schlafen perfekt war wir sind
blöd dass ich mich jetzt hier auf meinem
sonnenschirm ausruhe über nacht
allerdings habe ich meinen dad leider
nicht mitnehmen können weil mein ganzes
inventar voll ist mit sachen beziehen
wir jetzt nicht mehr weil ich halt viele
schon verbaut habe die sache ist
allerdings dass wir jetzt diese
gewalttour allen fächern nehmen und die
um das bettchen rom setzten nämlich auf
der linken und rechten seite wir fangen
recht jetzt einfach mal und jetzt denkt
ihr euch vielleicht hält das ist ja gelb
wird allerdings gleich so also es wird
gleich hier so
aussterben so ein bisschen die teile wir
töten die pflanzen zwar damit die sache
ist allerdings dass das halt wirklich
sehr sehr sehr sehr geil aussieht findet
wenn das so angeordnet dass sie halt
wirklich aussieht so ein kleiner teppich
ich denke mir allerdings gerade dass es
vielleicht auch ganz cool aussehen
könnte wenn ich diese teile hier weg
nehme diese drei und dann auch auf
dieser seite 1 2 3 so dass ich diese
sechs abgestorbenen geweiht hoch allen
fächern gibt es gleich drei namen dass
ich dir jetzt einfach mal hier so
hinsetzen kann vielleicht sind es ja
auch noch ein bisschen geradeaus geht es
teppich nicht ganz bis ans ende bis an
die wand ich das jetzt erst mal und ein
vorleger aber könnt ihr mir auch gerne
in die kommentare schreiben ob wir das
bis hierhin noch durchziehen würde
da kam das ziehen wir durch ich wohl
noch mal kurz sechs stück was soll denn
der geiz freunde
denn hier unten haben wir drei oder sind
sie das nicht dass andere wiederum
wenn man denn die 45 und nummer sechs so
perfekt die teilnahme auf jeden fall ist
müssen noch mal ganz kurz eben hoch
kommen jetzt du noch einmal und juno 5
haben wir jetzt wissen dass andere dinge
da schwimmt die runden sagt sechs stück
haben wir dann können wir jetzt auch
noch mit nach oben lägen ich will mal
ein fan davon sachen komplett
durchzuziehen und in meinem video was
die inspiration für diese strandhaus
bilder war das video seht ihr jetzt auch
endlich mit der beschreibung
eingeblendet ich habe es ein bisschen
anders gebaut an ein paar stellen gerade
auch was den außenbereich angeht weil
wir das ganze am wasser bauen aber ich
bin bei so was hier wirklich sehr
penibel genau dass das bis zum ende
durch sein sollte alles perfekt in einer
fuge in einer linie ihr wisst ja glaube
ich so der aufmerksame zuschauer
mitbekommen ich baue auch gerade meine
wohnung in köln so ein bisschen und da
bin ich auch gerade drauf und dran mir
inspirationen auch eine minecraft
projekt tatsächlich hier zu holen wir
dieser strandhaus will dann mache ich
auch einige sachen ähnlich hört sich
vielleicht ein bisschen dooley mäßig an
allerdings gerade so was das ganze
schlafzimmer angekündigt dass sie
wirklich extrem geil in minecraft
gemacht die sache ist allerdings dass
wir uns jetzt hier jetzt mal um den raum
kümmern und ihr seht ja schon das hier
ist offen da müssen wir nämlich auch
durch und das heißt dass wir dafür erst
mal zwei stufen nehmen oder nehmen wir
die klappe quatsch häufig dauert nehmen
lieber mal die klappe stufen und da
ziehen die hier so hinter mir nämlich
hier so den durchgang und platzieren
hier auch klassik treppen so dass das
dafür nämlich mal den blog hier einmal
ganz kurz ab perfekt das runtergefallen
und den ja auch so dass das hier so
aussieht dass wir so eine kleine
quasi dargestellt wie so eine schiebetür
die schiebe bedeuten wir jetzt mit
schwarzem glasscheiben an die wir hier
so hinsetzen und dann könnte man erahnen
dass das ja einfach so eine schiebetür
ist die so irgendwie zu gehen und ich
finde dass sie doch einen ganz geil aus
die sache ist jetzt dass wir nun die
glatten quarzwerke nehmen und die hier
wie folgt anordnen hier könnten wird
auch noch eine laterne nehmen die hier
mal hinsetzen das hier wird unsere
dass unser altern oder so waschbecken
hier haben wir jetzt auf jeden fall
einfach mal so einen hebel hin und hier
soll ein bisschen schnee was das
abfließende wasser darstellen soll den
schnee ordnung jetzt einfach mal so an
dass man erkennt okay das wasser fließt
in die richtung nun nehmen wir noch mal
unsere glatten quartzwerk und setzten
die hier oben wie folgt hin und hier
darunter auch noch einen und dann haben
wir jetzt ja auch noch ein paar glatter
quad treppen die können wir nun nämlich
hier so ein bisschen an orten damit
zumindest ein bisschen tiefe hier am
start haben und das ganze so dann hier
aus die
8er geht wegen der laterne oder
oder der schnee ist hier auf jeden fall
wieder weggegangen von der müssen wir
das jetzt glaube ich einfach offen
lassen allerdings ist das ihr alt nun
der linke bereich wenn man hier
reinkommt ins bad um der rechte bereich
der machen wir jetzt hier unten kommen
nämlich fünf kloster unglück verhindert
darüber eichenholz bretter rechts in der
mitte und links und dazwischen birken
lautete dass sich auch so ein bisschen
natur drin haben darum setzen wir nun an
die sie treffen die wir so anordnen und
dann auch hier einmal noch mal so drum
rum und barmen die verbinden sich und in
die mitte kommen drei an dieses labs
dass sie wird unser kleiner whirlpool
bzw badewanne wie auch immer man es
nennen mag in köln beispielsweise
brauche ich meine badewanne raus weil
ich wirklich gemerkt habe ich bin der
schlechteste badewannen gänger der welt
ich habe in meinen wohnungen der sechs
jahren eine badewanne und ich war an der
zeit
dreimal baden und von den drei mal war
ich dreimal krank diesen haken ich hab
ich jetzt auf jeden fall einfach noch
angebracht weil es wie ich finde sehr
danach aussieht als wenn das ein hebel
werde die man jetzt runter drückt und
dann geht er quasi wasser rein ist
allerdings ein bisschen anders als
dieser hebel weil er hier noch ein
bisschen holz sand ist und
dementsprechend den eichen holzbrettern
passt davor kommt jetzt auf jeden fall
fünf glatt steinstufen dies ein bisschen
den eintritt gewähren allerdings auch
ein gewisser materialmix dann hier
vorhanden ist und dem ganzen projekt und
hier vorne platz ich nun hier einen
quartz block und hier so dass sich
jemand gemälde hinsetzen kann das war
der rahmen so dass ich nun hier meinen
gemälde hinsetzen kann so dass wir hier
so ein schönes zweimaleins gemälde
hingesetzt bekommen und dann kommen wir
nun als allerletztes auch zu meiner
toilette der ort an dem ich leider
irgendwie täglich meiste zeit verbringen
dafür nämlich einfach so eine glatte
quartz treppe setzen so verkehrt herum
hinnehmen dann eine grob wege platte
also eine eisen druckplatte quasi
einfach 2000 waren im crafting feld
nebenan setzen dann kriegt ihr die sieht
allerdings am ähnlichsten aus die sonne
allerdings unsere quarz platz gibt es
leider nicht die sache ist allerdings
dass wir neben unseren rahmen nehmen die
nicht gerade missverständlicherweise
hier erst angebracht habe da reinpacken
nun einen stein knopf und in den stall
sehr klein da
brauchen einander
normalen steigen
das sieht schon sehr schön das egal ich
darf mich auf jeden fall nachher erst
loben wenn das ganze vorbei ist denn das
wichtigste fehlt natürlich noch und zwar
das klopapier das möchte ich so ein
bisschen mit einem stein knopf und dem
weißen banner darstellt ich sage auch
die ganzheitlich möchte dass du
darstellen ich habe das natürlich nicht
selbst ausgedacht diese strandhaus villa
wenn ich mir die selbst ausgedacht hätte
dann wären wahrscheinlich nur eine woche
keine videos gekommen so wie es gerade
der fall war sondern monatelang sei dass
das wirklich geistes kann wer sich das
ding hier ausgedacht hat der hat
wirklich meinen absoluten respekt
verdient link findet in der beschreibung
das gerne schön brewster in den
kommentaren die sache ist allerdings
dass generell und das hab ich ja noch
gar nicht angesprochen in der heutigen
folge die letzten tage kam keine videos
ich weiß den steinkopf weg den brauche
ich nicht die letzten tage kamen keine
videos ich hatte am mittwoch eine
impfung und danach habe ich eigentlich
erst mal nicht mehr hochgeladen für drei
vier tage weil es mir echt dreckig ging
ich habe mich versucht abzulenken mit
freunden nach köln gefahren um eine
wohnung weil ich doch einige termine
hatte und da war ich bis gerade eben
also bis vor 2 stunden und jetzt hab ich
mich hier direkt am pc gesetzt das video
vorbereitet und nehmen es jetzt auf ich
hoffe ihr könnt mir verzeihen dass jetzt
wirklich sechs tage lang ein video kam
es war allerdings wirklich so dass ich
eigentlich videos four produzieren
wollte wo die zeit wo ich in köln für
die zeit wo ich in köln war also dass
sich video parat habe und die vorher
schon genug produzieren
wo kommen die her
[Musik]
kommt ja
warum
hier ist alles ausgeleuchtet ist aber
auch egal ich wollte auf jeden fall
videos produzieren konnten allerdings
nicht machen aufgrund meiner impfung
deswegen jetzt geht's weiter jeden
zweiten tag in folge hier kommt jetzt
auf jeder stein knopfreihen so perfekt
er der stein rein das sieht auf jeden
fall gut aus den letzten weißen baradar
wieso geht das nicht
[Musik]
ach so das theresia sie muss den steinen
knopf hier raus neben dem schneiden und
muss ihnen doch zu einem stein knopf
machen allerdings den steinkopf nicht
hinein packen sondern so denn dann kann
ich den banner der einpacken und wenn
ich jetzt
das so dreher haben wir endlich das
toilettenpapier
und das finde ich ist schon ganz geil
wie das hier dargestellt wurde doch das
ist dann auch wirklich unsere stand haus
will meine lieben freunde das hier ist
unser badezimmer werden wir unseren
world womit der geilen indirekten
beleuchtung durch das kloster mit den
geilen mit dem mit der geilen
kombination generell überall aus holz
und laub und und natur genau das gleiche
was wir hier haben allerdings auch was
sich unten im eingangsbereich nach vorne
widerspiegelt wir haben ein extrem
extrem geile aussehende toilette und
elektrische schiebetür hier so ein
bisschen der waschbereich wir haben hier
unseren flachbildfernseher wir haben
hier unsere unser bett was sehr geil
aussieht finde ich mit diesem korallen
die dann bisschen abgestorben sind wir
haben unseren kleiderschrank wir haben
hier vorne einen richtig geilen
sternenhimmel stellt euch mal vor das
wär jetzt eine schneelandschaft
beziehungsweise in seiner winter region
und werden jetzt polarlichter das wäre
sehr sehr wild dann haben wir hier unser
wohnzimmer wo man ein bisschen chillen
kann wo man hier hinten den
sonnenuntergang sieht wir haben hier ein
bisschen depot wir haben hier
ablagefächer für bücher etc nun ist es
tatsächlich ein bisschen düster
vielleicht müssen uns doch ein bisschen
gedanken machen über indirekte
beleuchtung also wenn ihr den abschied
gerne in die kommentare wir haben hier
unsere
warum hätte ich ganz komisch gesprochen
ist aber egal wir haben hier vorne
unsere kleine bar bereich wir haben
vorne die schokolade was ihm in die
kommentare geschrieben habe wir haben
hier unsere becher bestehend aus
meersburg die höhe und damit auch
unseren essbereich mit dem schönen glas
tisch wir haben wir unser kleines feuer
die kleine feuerstelle die wir ja wo wir
einige probleme hatten wir das erst auf
der anderen seite sichtbare haben
allerdings land einfach doppelt gezogen
an unseren pool hier am start mit dem
schirm wo drin man auch schlafen kann
mit den sesseln wir haben dort hinten
unsere yacht ich gehe auch mal ganz das
bett ist weit entfernt
jetzt gehts meine lieben freunde ich
glaube ich wissen mittlerweile die stadt
aus wieder aussieht ich muss jetzt nicht
jeden einzelnen winkel von zeigen ich
habe ja noch diese yacht hier vorne mit
drangesetzt jemand unserem kleinen
indoor garten damit unseren ganzen
eingangsbereich und mit dem schmelzen
und so es ist wirklich sehr sehr geil
ich weiß nicht so häufig wie hier
wirklich drin werden ich wollte
allerdings einfacher auch etwas modernes
und diese welt herr einbauen allerdings
hoffe ich dass es euch gefallen hat
dieses riesige projekt strandhaus villa
wir sind fast am ende des ganzen
projekts minecraft mit luca von daher
das gern einen daumen hoch und ein video
hier da aber neben den kanal falls noch
kein tethering pro seite und klickt auf
die glocke in dem das nächste video
minecraft in lucka nicht verpassen
wollte vielleicht kommt übermorgen
vielleicht auch erst in vier tagen wenn
ich übermorgen andere gute idee habe ich
denke allerdings wir sehen uns nur am
morgen wieder weil ich bock haben das
ganze jahr zu einem coolen ende zu ende
zu bringen also wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder
[Musik]